hey youtubers is Charlie and we got a
whole lot of arrows stuff to talk about
we got a brand new trailer introducing
us to the Ra's al Ghul of this universe
as well as a new character announced
they just announced the Ted grant
Wildcat is coming on the show this video
is mostly just gonna be about the
trailer so I'm gonna do a separate video
for Wildcat later this week don't worry
I'm also doing the Batman vs Superman
trailer this week too but hello new
people if you're just finding me for the
first time or you found me during all
the comic-con stuff I do arrow and flash
videos every week be sure to subscribe
to get everything
I'll also be announcing my giveaway
winner at the end of this video so let's
just rip apart the trailer frame for
frame right off the bat you see the
brand new motion logo that Warner
Brothers rolled out for arrow they
basically made a red flash one for that
show and our rainy depressing one for
Gotham it's like they uploaded custom
banners for all the new DC TV shows I
didn't see Constantine one but they
might just not have revealed that yet or
might be a weird NBC Network thing the
opening voiceover where ever Oliver's
looking at over the city is a line that
Huntress had during season two I
actually almost thought it was Thea
which would actually be pretty cool but
really this first half of the trailer is
just a recap of season 2 so everything
is taken from those episodes that line
once you let the darkness in is from
that birds-of-prey episode whenever they
put hunters in jail we see a bunch of
WTF action scenes and the progression of
Deathstroke's plan to crush Oliver into
darkness by killing Moira and everyone
else and everything he loves this is the
first problem of this season so
essentially they have to just teach all
the new people who are finding air for
the first time what happened if he did
watch season 2 then you know Oliver was
galvanized into a hero so whenever
season 3 starts off he's like full-on
hero persona and here's where we all
cheered cuz this is where the new
footage is the opening line is from a
new character masayo Yamashiro he's
played by Karl Yune he's going to be
Oliver's Diggle in the Hong Kong
flashbacks like the Diggle before there
was a Diggle
his wife is katana it's possible that in
the flashbacks she won't be calling
herself katana because in the comics she
didn't take that name until her husband
was murdered we'll just have to wait and
see how closely arrow is gonna stick to
the comics for some of those characters
when he's talking about when he says a
man can't live by two names is obviously
the superhero persona and the real-life
alter-ego persona in the flashbacks
Oliver still has not become the arrow
like he's not the vigilante even
is he all over a queen billionaire or is
he gonna try and be a force for good the
context in the show with which this line
was said is a little bit weird because
in the Hong Kong flashbacks Messiah and
katana are Oliver's handlers they work
for Waller and Argus Oliver is kind of
forced to work for Waller but we'll see
that a little bit later in the trailer
together the three of them are just
gonna try and make the best of a bad
situation and learn how to serve justice
while still being under the thumb of
Argus it's Oliver learning to be the
better man despite Amanda Waller trying
to turn him into a killer so then we see
Oliver back at Queen industries which is
kind of weird because most of last
season was spent outside of the
boardroom I guess you could say it's
what's left of Queen industries after
Slade and Isabelle's influence had been
purged I'm not sure if she ran it into
the ground or she just pushed Oliver out
but I'll explain more about that in a
sec when we see Brandon rouse character
the blue looking scene is connected to
the new medium bad Werner's Erdal also
called count vertigo played by Peter
Stormare it's probably his lab where he
manufactures the vertigo drug so this
next scene with Oliver and Laurel is a
bit of a misdirect it's actually
connected to a couple other scenes when
she says that she and all of our
business partners she basically helps
Oliver get the funds to buy back Queen
industries remember he doesn't have any
money
thus she becomes his new business
partner but wait in this next scene Ray
Palmer known as the atom swoops in or
shrinks in I guess I should say Brendon
Roth is essentially coming in the show
as an investor in Oliver's company like
that's his entrance into the story that
makes him Oliver's new boss so cue the
funny music it's gonna be really awkward
at first it's not a bad thing and
Stephen Amell even said during Comic Con
at interviews that he doesn't view Ray
Palmer in a negative light he is another
future Justice League member who
eventually is going to join team arrow
at least later this season
it's just when they first meet it's a
little bit weird plus he's also going to
be competing with Oliver for Felicity's
affections I know a lot of you Ola city
shippers are gonna grind your teeth but
Brandon Roth is a totally cool dude so
this is actually gonna be fun just roll
with it trust me everything will be put
right by the end of the season no matter
how badly the ship has shaken up Ray
Palmer's business relationship with
Oliver well of course over time turned
into a nighttime vigilante relationship
that's one of the major arcs of the
season the evolution of Ray Palmer into
the atom so here's where we get into
what I'm gonna think of is like a
modified Connor Hawke storyline
they're basically giving to Diggle it's
Oliver explaining to Diggle that because
he's got mini Diggle he can't keep
putting himself in danger Diggle in
LYLAS baby will be another big arc for
David Ramsey Diggle balancing fatherhood
with nighttime activities I know
everyone wanted to see a real connor
hawke arc with Oliver especially after
his son was teased during season two but
it seems like they're basically giving
that to diggle's character not that
Diggle son's gonna grow up to be a
member of team arrow it's just that
they're doing the superhero slash father
storyline for his character then here's
the first look at Peter Stormare count
vertigo I don't know if he's gonna call
himself that or if he's just gonna be an
affectation that other people attached
to him because of all the vertigo he
sells his real name is Werner zurtle I
think that when he's talking to Oliver
in that voiceover about refusing to die
he's referring to the big attack that
comes during season one during the
olicity date as well as all the stuff
during season two I feel like Cyril was
actually kind of sitting on the fringe
watching all the Slade stuff go on and
just waiting for a moment to swoop in
I'm interested to see if count vertigo
has any history with Starling city or
with Oliver specifically like he might
end up tying into the Hong Kong
flashbacks too but it's not confirmed
then we finally see Kate Lots in her
black leather kicking but again they
announced she was coming back so it's
not a huge surprise but it's kind of
hard to tell who's as she's kicking it
might just be a random person and she
might be helping out there are a couple
scenes later in the trailer that connect
to this the way they edited it is a
little confusing the hoodie person is
not the person she just took down her
next scene with her talking to Oliver is
actually directly from last season the
one where she took off the episode where
she took off to go back to Nanda Parbat
it's basically teeing up the olicity arc
that's gonna be a big deal this year and
when I say olicity I'm just talking
about the show dealing with their sexual
tension in a more literal context like
they're gonna work through it episode by
episode cut to said proposal and said
olicity date Stephen Amell was actually
asked about this at Comic Con surprise
surprise
how their date went he basically laughed
and just said horribly you'll see why in
a sec but their conversation it's all
about Oliver explaining his time in Hong
Kong I'm always amazed by the number of
things that Oliver has not revealed to
his other team arrow partners yet cut -
of course
Hong Kong parkour I believe this person
is Karl Yune again it's probably when he
and Oliver first meet he's not just his
handler and his friend he's also going
to continue to train Oliver with
Tanna but it doesn't look like it starts
out is a very happy relationship like
Waller tells Masayo Carly in this
character to keep Oliver from escaping
from running away the next scene with
Waller explains that a little bit better
Oliver is trying to escape Hong Kong and
get back to the mainland and Wohlers
trying to keep him there to serve her
purpose whatever that is
I love how those green cloth in the
background foreshadowing much then this
is just another scene of Oliver trying
to escape that Park or fight with Masayo
then we cut back to present and we see
Oliver with caity lotz on that rooftop
the same one where she was kicking that
guy's butt but it's also the big reveal
of colton in his red arrow costume for
everyone wondering which version of Roy
he is in the comics he's the Arsenal
version Stephen Amell joked that he now
has the second best costume on the show
just because Colton's looks so cool and
he's right Roy's costume is way better
than Oliver's then we finally catch up
with Quentin I know everyone had a bunch
of questions about him after the finale
because he basically had like half his
guts ripped out
remember this is happening like several
months after the events of the finale so
he's fully healed here he is in his
captain's uniform with the shaved head
and a hat which I know it's a little bit
weird this is gonna be his costume for
season 3 so to speak
Paul blackboard does look a little bit
strange at first with a shaved head but
I totally dig it the bright light they
have him in framed here just pretty much
tells you that he is riding high like
he's doing pretty good he's essentially
in a position of power now and he can
use the police force to help team arrow
rather than hunt them down then WTF is
this Star City I know a lot of you comic
book fans will get excited about this in
the comics Star City is the name of
Oliver Queen's home Starling city is
just something that arrow changed it
looks like part of Ray Palmer's plans
for Queen industries once he takes over
is to rejuvenate Starling city in some
way or rebranded it seems kind of
strange I know but think of Starling
city is an analogue for coast city in
the comics that one was destroyed during
reign of the Superman that was a long
time ago I could actually remember
reading those comics Hank Henshaw the
cyborg superman essentially wiped it off
the face of the map eventually with the
help of Earth's superheroes and the
Green Lantern Corps the city was rebuilt
and rebranded as the city without fear
that was also a big tie-in to the
Sinestro Corps war which was a Geoff
Johns comic so it was a whole big thing
I love how you can see Geoff Johns
fingerprints all over eros story
but he's just ridden a lot of different
superhero comics at DC so you're gonna
bump into him pretty frequently on arrow
Ray Palmer is gonna be like a tech giant
like a tech genius so obviously whatever
his plan is for Starling city it's gonna
involve tech this fandom based heart
attack is actually what happens during
the olicity date or after it in that
first episode so now you understand why
Stephen Amell said their date goes
horribly she's obviously gonna recover
but this is the event that shocks Oliver
awake he's kind of been coasting on his
laurels since Slade got stuck in that
Argost prison and then we get that line
I know everyone's excited to hear him
say it again you have failed this city
we don't see who he's saying it to but
usually when he says it to someone it's
a person with deep connections to
Starling like deep roots in the city
which I'm guessing is not count vertigo
so it might be Merlyn he's talking to
but we don't know when he'll make his
first season three appearance John
Barrowman is a cast regular so he's
gonna be in most the episodes I'm
assuming he's gonna be in that first one
and then here's the icing on the cake
though Ra's al Ghul's scene it's just a
teaser the reason we don't see his face
is because they haven't cast the role
yet either they haven't found someone or
they found someone and they just haven't
announced who it is yet I can't remember
when I started making Ra's al Ghul
predictions I think we all expected him
to be like a post-credits teaser in the
season 2 finale so it's kind of
disappointing we didn't see him then but
I feel like the show has been building
to him for so long that it was just
inevitable so I feel like arrow doing
Ross logo isn't a huge surprise the real
surprise is them announcing it this
early usually they try to say big stuff
like this until the episodes air other
than wanting to kill Merlyn just out of
spite
there are only a few reasons they would
bring himself to Starling I'm gonna say
it probably has something to do with
Wohlers actions in the Hong Kong
flashbacks and count vertigo in the
present all these new characters and all
the new storylines have to connect by
the finale so I'm really interested to
see how they connect the dots all the
way from Oliver to Amanda Waller in Hong
Kong - count vertigo to katana
all the way up to Raja Ghul and Merlyn
like they all have to intersect by that
last episode and that doesn't even cover
the flash crossover I'm interested to
see how they deal with the flash
characters overlapping with the new
arrow characters or if it's just gonna
be like some special self-contained plot
it sounds like based on what they're
saying the two different parts of it
episode 8 on both shows respectively
will tie into the bigger arcs of each
different shows season
like the villains of flash will overlap
with the villains on arrow and will take
both sets of superheroes coming together
to stop them like a mini Justice League
episode that's just my opinion they
haven't teased anything about those
episodes yet but let me know what are
you most excited about after watching
this trailer I know everyone is freaking
out about Ra's al Ghul and it is gonna
be really awesome but now let's talk
about the Ted grant Wildcat jr. Ramirez
has been cast and it looks like they're
going full on with the boxing aspects of
his character in the comics Ted grant
was a prizefighter that started wearing
a costume and kicking bad guys butts he
was a core member of the Justice Society
and as you can see here some recommended
reading for his backstory is sensation
Comics number one JSA classified eight
and nine and Batman Wildcat one through
three Geoff Johns actually wrote the
Justice Society comic about ten years
ago so again you see his influence but
I'll be doing a separate Wildcat video
later this week be sure to subscribe to
get it
now let's announce the winner of my
arrow Comic Con giveaway Congrats to
Carl caster you went a green arrow Funko
pop figure I'll be messaging you on your
channel for details so be sure to check
your email unless the winner of my flash
giveaway whenever I post a flash video
later this week I'm doing a separate
flash video right now you can click here
to learn all about that first episode of
arrow season 3 and click here for my
review of the first episode of the flash
I do a non-spoilery part at the
beginning it's amazing you guys are
gonna love it thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tomorrow
high fives
you